my name is Nikki ander I'm the executive
chef of Martina pizzeria here in the
East Village where a fine casual Roman
inspired pizzeria that's open from 11:00
a.m. until late into the night when I
was a student in Rome I was studying our
history and I kept yet distracted by
trapped areas pizzerias I just loved how
cheap and easy it was to get hold of
delicious delicious pizza just at any
time of the day so the pizza Martina is
definitely inspired by this thin crust
Roman style very different in the
Neapolitan style which has a puff yard
crust I'm a big fan of crispier pizzas
things that are touched thinner you have
to be really delicate with the thin
crust pizza you can't over top it but
you don't want to under top it either I
think it's kind of like this the speed
of physics where you're getting this
dough to kind of support everything on
every single bite and then the topping
is really shine and you can actually
like crush two or three of them in a
sitting
so the way that we make our feet set
Martina is we first take the dough out
of the refrigerator we ferment at cold
temperatures that we can do a long slow
fermentation we let it come up to room
temperature and that allows the dough to
sorta come back to life a little bit
we're looking for flavor more than
anything else with our fermentation not
necessarily air pockets so we roll it
with a rolling pin until it gets very
flat about ten inches in diameter then
we take the sauce about two ounces of
sauce not too much and then just evenly
spread it all the way to the edge and
make sure the center doesn't get super
heavy with sauce once that sauce
foundation was laid down then we take
our really simple toppings if we're
doing a sausage pizza crumbled small
bits of sausage a light sprinkling of
cremini mushrooms and then two kinds of
cheese pecorino Toscano and mozzarella
or two are the ones that we mix a lot
you get a lot of that Tang from the
pecorino you get the sweetness from the
mozzarella pop it in the oven we're
using an oven that we cook at about 700
degrees for these pizzas we don't want
to cook it too too hot we like a fully
cooked dough that spends a little bit
more time on the floor instead of it
spending like 60 to 90 seconds we're
actually spending like a full two
minutes try to hit it on like a spot
that's a little bit away from the flame
cook it there for about a minute and a
half and then give it like 30 seconds of
a kiss like right by that hot fire
doesn't sound like a big difference in
time with that extra 30 seconds to a
minute actually accepts the sear both on
the top and also on the bottom then we
pull them out and this is a really
important part as we land it directly
onto a rack so that the underside of the
piece of that upskirt has a chance to
breathe a little bit and allow some that
steam to escape so you get that nice
crispy bottom we always check the
bottoms you always see me like
fanatically checking the upskirt you
lift the pizza up and look underneath to
make sure that everything is it's
looking good and evenly charred there
then you go ahead and slice it into four
pieces and give it to the lead
[Music]
so we're open till about 1:00 a.m. on
the weekends and we see a fair amount of
people both in the industry and also in
the neighborhood that are looking for a
quick bite before they go to bed so you
know between 11:00 p.m. and 1:00 a.m.
people are strolling in grabbing a pie
maybe two or three and a half bottle of
champagne I'd like the transition of
going from fine dining to this fine
casual atmosphere from the first day
that we opened I felt like we had
neighbors coming in that were already
regulars by the second week cuz when a
small space and you can see all four
corners of room you can see every face
every night you get to know people a
little quicker Martina we're calling a
fine casual pizzeria and what does that
exactly mean it means that when people
come in this door they want to have the
same feeling of hospitality that they
get when they walk into any fine-dining
restaurant